Oh God I don't know I'm trying to avoid
avoiding nickname Robert Pattinson is
our new Dark Knight this is our first
look of Pattinson as the Batman the
whole rides been really great I mean
since I've been incredibly lucky in my
career in my life
director Matt Reeves tweeted a short
camera test video featuring the Twilight
star all suited up
this brief glimpse of Pattinson jawline
will have to do for now the Batman is
set to be released next summer will you
settle debate for me are we doing our
bats are we doing batten I'm trying to
avoid avoiding nicknames et also act
Pattinson about facing off against
Catwoman who will be played by zoe
kravitz we're so excited for the batman
zoe kravitz coming at us as Catwoman how
worthy of an adversary she were you a
big fan of hers yes oh he's great and I
understand I've known a few years and
years and years I mean I think we've run
stuff like 10 years and so it's uh yeah
she's she's playing Pattinson has also
gotten the stamp of approval from fellow
Bruce Wayne Christian Bell now here at
if there are there are two Batman here
we have Robert Pattinson here and you're
here as well Oh hold all the best to
admit you know I think is absolutely
fantastic actor wonderful choice for
Batman
[Music]